This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Back in the late 1980s, when Luis Gio was a little kid growing up in Colombia, he and his brother didn't have babysitters. They had bodyguards. His parents would send them to school in an SUV that was accompanied by another identical SUV, which was a decoy. Because that meant if one of the vehicles was attacked, there would be a chance it would not be in it. That's Luis. Our life was strange in many ways back then.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。在上世纪 80 年代末，当路易斯·吉奥（Luis Gio）还是哥伦比亚的一个小男孩时，他和哥哥是没有保姆的。他们有保镖。父母会让他们坐一辆 SUV 去上学，后面还会跟着一辆一模一样的 SUV 作为诱饵。因为这意味着如果其中一辆车遭到袭击，他们就有可能不在那辆车上。那是路易斯。当时我们的生活在很多方面都很奇怪。
My brother and I had our own bedrooms, but every night our whole family would sleep in the same room. It had a door to the back patio and a ladder ready to use in case we needed to flee. My parents made it seem like we were just having a slumber party. But the real reason that Luis's family took these precautions is that Luis's dad was a captain in the anti-narcotics unit for Columbia's National Police. In Pablo Escobar, the notorious drug lord
我和哥哥有各自的卧室，但每天晚上我们全家人都会睡在同一个房间里。房间通往后院露台，还准备了一把梯子，以防我们需要逃跑。我父母把它弄得像我们在开睡衣派对一样。但路易斯一家采取这些防范措施的真正原因，是路易斯的父亲担任哥伦比亚国家警察缉毒局的一名队长。在巴勃罗·埃斯科瓦尔，这个声名狼藉的毒枭
had declared war on the police, on the whole Colombian state, really. It's become a typical day in Colombia, three more judges have quit their jobs after being threatened. By the murderous drug cartels, the government has imposed a curfew in nine cities in the heart of cocaine country, including the cartels capital Medaín. But the late 80s and early 90s, Escobar was supplying 80% of the world's cocaine. And the violence and rounding the drug trade had gotten really bad. The epicenter of the world's cocaine. And the violence surrounding the drug trade had gotten really bad. The epicenter of the violence was Medellin.
向警察，乃至整个哥伦比亚国家宣战了。这已经成为哥伦比亚的典型一天，又有三名法官在遭到武装毒贩威胁后辞职，政府在可卡因王国腹地的九个城市实施了宵禁，包括贩毒集团的首都麦德林。但在 80 年代末和 90 年代初，埃斯科瓦尔供应了世界上 80% 的可卡因。毒品贸易带来的暴力和混乱已经变得非常严重。世界可卡因的震中。毒品贸易周围的暴力已经变得非常严重。暴力的震中是麦德林。
Escobar's cartel was based there, and they controlled much of the city. 13 bombs have gone off the median since the weekend, all aimed at government-owned banks or state liquor stores. Medellin became the most dangerous city in the world. In 1991 alone, around 6,000 people were killed. The murder rate was almost 400 people per 100,000 residents, which to put things in perspective, that's three or four times more than the most violent cities in the world today. But today, my de genie is very different.
埃斯科瓦尔的贩毒集团总部就在那里，他们控制了这座城市的大部分地区。周末以来，麦德林已经发生了 13 起爆炸事件，目标全部是政府所有的银行或国有酒类商店。麦德林成为了世界上最危险的城市。仅在 1991 年，就有大约 6,000 人被杀害。谋杀率几乎达到每 10 万居民中有 400 人，从长远来看，这比当今世界上最暴力的城市还要高出三到四倍。但今天，我的麦德林已经非常不同了。
In just 30 years, it's changed from being the bloody cooking capital of the world into a place that's often described as a model city. It's now safer than many cities in the US, and amazingly, one of the things that helped to pull the city out of the violence was a whole new approach to urban planning, including a major overhaul of the city's public transportation system. Luis' family experienced Colombia as many changes. Luis is now a journalist, and he's gonna help us tell the story of what happened, along with Maria Inahosa, the host of NPR's Latino USA.
仅仅用了 30 年，它就从世界上血腥的烹饪（应为可卡因）之都变成了一个常被称为模范城市的地方。它现在的安全性甚至超过了美国的许多城市，令人惊叹的是，帮助这座城市摆脱暴力的方法之一是一种全新的城市规划方法，包括对城市公共交通系统的大规模改造。路易斯的家人经历了哥伦比亚的许多变化。路易斯现在是一名记者，他将和 NPR 节目《拉丁美洲人》的主持人玛丽亚·伊诺霍萨（Maria Hinojosa）一起，帮我们讲述曾经发生的故事。
She covered the violence in Medellin back in the 1980s, and she went back again last year to explore the city with Luis. All right, so. So we are here in downtown Medellin. You were here 30 years ago. What was it like when you came? Yeah, no, I remember that when we came to this particular part, but I just remember walking here and feeling very afraid
她曾在 20 世纪 80 年代报道过麦德林的暴力事件，去年她又回到了那里，与路易斯一起探索这座城市。好吧，所以。所以我们现在在麦德林市中心。你 30 年前就在这里。你来的时候这里是什么样子的？是的，不，我记得当我们来到这个特定的地方时，我只记得走在这里，感到非常害怕
feeling very afraid because Everybody knew that at any moment anywhere a bomb could go off Our story today is a collaboration with Latino USA Everybody knew that at any moment, anywhere a bomb could go off. Our story today is a collaboration with Latino USA. Medellin sits in a valley surrounded by steep, green mountains. In the city's early days, the mountains were undeveloped. But during the first half of the 20th century, the city rapidly industrialized. More and more people came to Medellin for manufacturing and textile jobs, and they began building homes and communities of the sides of those mountains.
感到非常害怕，因为每个人都知道，随时随地都可能发生炸弹爆炸。我们今天的故事是与《拉丁美洲人》合作推出的。每个人都知道，随时随地都可能发生炸弹爆炸。我们今天的故事是与《拉丁美洲人》合作推出的。麦德林坐落在一个被陡峭的绿色山脉环绕的山谷中。在这座城市的早期，这些山脉尚未开发。但在 20 世纪的前半叶，这座城市迅速工业化。越来越多的人来到麦德林寻找制造和纺织工作，他们开始在这些山坡上建造房屋和社区。
These informal settlements became known as Camunas. The Camunas were really thought of as separate from the rest of the city below, both because of their geographical distance from downtown and also because they were neglected by city government. They didn't receive the same services as other neighborhoods. Public transit didn't reach them. It would take more than an hour to get from the farthest camuna to the city center. People in the camuna used to say,
这些非法定居点被称为“卡姆纳斯”（Comunas，即贫民窟）。人们真的认为卡姆纳斯与下面城市的其他部分是隔绝的，既因为它们距离市中心的地理距离，也因为它们被市政府忽视了。它们没有得到与其他社区相同的服务。公共交通没有延伸到那里。从最远的卡姆纳斯到市中心需要一个多小时。卡姆纳斯的人们过去常说：
I need to go to Medean to run an errand, even though they were technically living in Medean. But as the manufacturing economy boomed and as city officials looked the other way, the communists kept growing until the hills above the city were crowded with houses, stacked on top of each other like colorful boxes. But by the 1980s, many of Colombia's manufacturing jobs were moving overseas and as manufacturing was tanking, the drug trade was skyrocketing. The Medean cartel began recruiting young people, mostly young men from the Camunas. These were young people who felt disconnected from the wider city, and they didn't have a lot of other options for jobs.
我需要去麦德林办点事，尽管他们技术上就住在麦德林。但随着制造业经济的繁荣，随着城市官员睁一只眼闭一只眼，贫民窟不断扩大，直到城市上方的山丘上挤满了房屋，像彩色盒子一样堆叠在一起。但到了 20 世纪 80 年代，哥伦比亚的许多制造工作都转移到了海外，随着制造业的崩盘，毒品贸易急剧飙升。麦德林贩毒集团开始招募年轻人，主要是来自卡姆纳斯的年轻男性。这些年轻人感到与更广泛的城市脱节，他们没有太多其他的工作选择。
This is Manuel Espinazo. He says that back in 1989, he lived two blocks from where Pablo Esclar Gaviri was born. making fast money, dealing drugs, or were you going to kind of, you know, become something else? What did that look like? Manuel says he started seeing friends with motorcycles in nice clothes. They talked about working for the narcos for a few months to get fast cash. They had money to party on the weekend and became the neighborhood's playboy. The guy who was going to the bar. By this point, Pablo Escobar had been running the Medellin Cartel for more than a decade. Forbes magazine had recently featured him in its billionaires issue
这是曼努埃尔·埃斯皮纳索（Manuel Espinazo）。他说，早在 1989 年，他就住在巴勃罗·埃斯科瓦尔·加维里亚出生的地方两街区之外。是通过贩毒赚快钱，还是打算……你知道的，成为别的东西？那是什么样子的？曼努埃尔说，他开始看到朋友们骑着摩托车，穿着漂亮的衣服。他们谈论着为毒枭工作几个月以赚取快钱。他们周末有钱开派对，成了社区的花花公子。那个去酒吧的人。此时，巴勃罗·埃斯科瓦尔执掌麦德林贩毒集团已经超过十年了。《福布斯》杂志最近在亿万富翁专刊中刊登了他
with the provocative headline, Presidente Don Pablo. And that wasn't a huge stretch. Through his network of informants, Escobar controlled much of Manellín and other parts of the country. He cultivated a Robin Hood-type image. Building housing and soccer fields in the communes, he was a hero to some of Manuel's friends. Manuel says he played soccer on a dirt field field and the games would end at sundown.
并配有挑衅性的标题“唐·巴勃罗总统”。这并不算夸张。通过他的情报员网络，埃斯科瓦尔控制了麦德林和该国其他大部分地区。他树立了罗宾汉式的形象。在贫民窟建造房屋和足球场，他是曼努埃尔的一些朋友心目中的英雄。曼努埃尔说他在泥地足球场踢球，比赛总是在日落时结束。
But one day, a rich man came to celebrate the construction of a new lighting system that would allow them to play at night. And guess who the man was? Geneseñor. Parescoar. Manuel says that Escobar was very different from other rich men, because he was generous. He was a benefactor. He was also becoming, in many ways, more powerful than the Colombian state.
但有一天，一个有钱人来庆祝一项新照明系统的建设，这个系统能让他们在晚上踢球。你猜那个男人是谁？Geneseñor。帕雷斯科阿尔（指巴勃罗·埃斯科瓦尔）。曼努埃尔说，埃斯科瓦尔与其他有钱人非常不同，因为他很慷慨。他是一个恩人。在许多方面，他也变得比哥伦比亚国家更有权势。
To try to solve this problem, Colombian law enforcement began relying on militarized policing tactics. Increasingly violent clashes started happening between the cartel and the police. Law enforcement would go into the Camuna's to try to control the drug trafficking, and sometimes they'd end up killing young men from those neighborhoods. Then, after years of conflict between Escobar and Colombian authorities, the U.S. started its war on drugs and passed an extradition agreement with the Colombian government. That meant that if or when Escobar was captured,
为了试图解决这个问题，哥伦比亚执法部门开始依赖军事化的警务战术。贩毒集团和警察之间开始爆发越来越暴力的冲突。执法人员会进入卡姆纳斯试图控制毒品走私，有时他们最终会杀死这些社区的年轻人。然后，在埃斯科瓦尔与哥伦比亚当局多年的冲突之后，美国开始了其禁毒战争，并通过了与哥伦比亚政府的引渡协议。这意味着如果或当埃斯科瓦尔被捕时，
he could potentially spend the rest of his life in a U.S. prison. The violence he made in China got a lot worse. It may have been a bomb that blew up a plane in Colombia today, the Boeing 727 of Avianca Airlines in the year 1989. In November of 1989, the Medellin Cartel bombed an Avianca aircraft, mid-flight, killing all 107 people on board. The cartel was trying to kill a Colombian presidential candidate. The bombing of flight 203 was the deadliest single attack in decades of violence in Colombia.
他可能会在美式监狱里度过余生。他在中国（应为麦德林）制造的暴力事件变得更加严重。今天哥伦比亚炸毁一架飞机的可能是一枚炸弹，1989 年阿维安卡航空公司的波音 727。1989 年 11 月，麦德林贩毒集团在飞行途中炸毁了一架阿维安卡航空公司的飞机，机上 107 人全部遇难。贩毒集团企图暗杀哥伦比亚总统候选人。203号航班爆炸案是哥伦比亚数十年暴力事件中最致命的单次袭击。
Two Americans were among the dead, prompting then-President George H. W. Bush to offer support to the Colombian forces in their search for Escobar. With additional American resources, the operatives trained to capture Escobar mounted dozens of raids. But he had so many informants in the government that he kept on getting away. And he retaliated. The Medellin cartel went on a killing spree that shook Colombia, and specially Medellin to its foundation.
死者中有两名美国人，这促使时任总统老布什向哥伦比亚军队搜捕埃斯科瓦尔提供支持。有了更多的美国资源，训练有素以抓捕埃斯科瓦尔的特工发动了数十次突袭。但他在政府里有太多的眼线，以至于他一次次逃脱。而他进行了报复。麦德林贩毒集团展开了一场震惊哥伦比亚、尤其是动摇了麦德林根基的大屠杀。
This was when the city became the murderer capital of the world. Sandra Arenas, Tessie, was total chaos. She's a sociologist in Medellin, who studied the armed conflict and how it affected the city. Savia Cicario, Savia, Grupos, Bandas del Inquencial, espelhando entre ellos, Savia. She says there were regular assassinations and fights among rival gangs. There were car bombs going off all the time. But especially that sensation of the dangerous street. She says that a sense of fear took over the streets. There was a feeling that anyone could die at any time.
正是在这个时候，这座城市成为了世界的谋杀之都。桑德拉·阿雷纳斯（Sandra Arenas），特西（Tessie，应为译音或误读），当时是一片混乱。她是麦德林的一位社会学家，研究过武装冲突及其对这座城市的影响。Savia Cicario, Savia, Grupos, Bandas del Inquencial, espelhando entre ellos, Savia（西班牙语：暗杀者、帮派等在其中互相厮杀）。她说，当时经常发生暗杀和敌对帮派之间的斗争。汽车炸弹随时都在爆炸。但尤其是那种危险街道的感觉。她说，一种恐惧感占据了街道。有一种感觉，任何人随时都可能死去。
Not only cartel members or police officers, anyone. Public spaces that had once been lively started emptying out to maintain control the cartel imposed a curfew. Escobar's men would throw leaflets from helicopters or bring people to stay inside past 8 p.m. The violence felt indiscriminate. Adena described the era as feeling like a long black night. Arenas described the era as feeling like a long black night. Of Escobar's top lieutenants, only four are left alive today, and three of them are still in prison abroad. The only one who is alive and in Colombia today is John Hydero Velasquez,
不仅仅是贩毒集团成员或警察，任何人都是如此。曾经热闹的公共空间开始变得空空荡荡，为了维持控制，贩毒集团实施了宵禁。埃斯科瓦尔的手下会从直升机上扔下传单，或者强迫人们在晚上 8 点后呆在室内。暴力感觉是不加区分的。阿雷纳斯将那个时代形容为漫长的黑夜。阿雷纳斯将那个时代形容为漫长的黑夜。在埃斯科瓦尔的高级副手中，今天活着的只有四个，其中三个仍在国外的监狱里。今天唯一活着并在哥伦比亚的是约翰·海德罗·贝拉斯克斯（John Hydero Velasquez），
also known as Bobbeye, or Popeye in English. In 1989, that was the most important and the hurricane that was the war. That's Popeye, Pablo Escobar's right-hand man in Topassassin. He served 23 years in prison, but he can still vividly recall the most intense year of the conflict. We're fighting in the streets, we're fighting in the streets, we're killing police officers and having shootouts in the streets, blocked by block, car bombs are going off in Medellin.
也被称为鲍比（Bobbeye），或者英文里的“大力水手”（Popeye）。1989 年，那是战争中最重要也最猛烈的飓风。那是“大力水手”，巴勃罗·埃斯科瓦尔的得力助手兼头号杀手。他在监狱里服刑 23 年，但对冲突最激烈的那个年份依然记忆犹新。我们在街头战斗，我们在街头战斗，我们杀死警察并在街头枪战，一个街区接一个街区，汽车炸弹在麦德林不断爆炸。
Popeye would eventually admit to killing over 250 people. And for this, he had help. He used to operate in the communas, getting to know the young men who lived in those impoverished and ignored neighborhoods on the outskirts of the city. Then he'd recruit them and train them as secarios, or hitmen. Escobar and his top leaders, like Popeye, had figured out how to exploit the geographic fragmentation of Managing.
“大力水手”最终承认杀害了 250 多人。为此，他得到了帮助。他过去常在贫民窟活动，结识那些住在城市边缘被贫困和忽视的社区里的年轻人。然后他会招募他们，将他们训练成 sicarios（杀手）。埃斯科瓦尔和他的高级头目（如“大力水手”）已经弄清楚了如何利用麦德林的地理分裂。
They knew that kids in the Camunas didn't have a lot of opportunities, and so that's where they focused their efforts. Even now he can't resist recruiting in a way, talking up how exciting it was to work for us Cabaar. Mira, Pablo Escobar Gavira para nosotros no era un padre, no era un amigo, no era un patron, no era un jefe, era un Dios. Pablo Escobar, for us, was not a boss or a friend. He was a god. Pablo Escobar Gavira never disrespected us. We would eat at the table with him.
他们知道卡姆纳斯的儿童没有太多机会，所以这就是他们集中精力的地方。即使现在他也有点抗拒不了招募，大肆宣扬为埃斯科瓦尔工作是多么令人兴奋。Mira, Pablo Escobar Gavira para nosotros no era un padre, no era un amigo, no era un patron, no era un jefe, era un Dios（西班牙语：看，巴勃罗·埃斯科瓦尔·加维里亚对我们来说不是父亲，不是朋友，不是老板，不是上司，他是神）。巴勃罗·埃斯科瓦尔对我们来说，不是老板也不是朋友。他是神。巴勃罗·埃斯科瓦尔·加维里亚从未不尊重我们。我们与他同桌吃饭。
We were in his orgies. We would die for Paolo and would go to prison for him. The Medellín Cartel was a big family. When Maria Inahosa, Luis's reporting partner, was a younger reporter, she came to Medellín to cover the conflict for Rolling Stone and other news outlets. And she remembers getting threats from the cartel. And Papa tells her that, yeah, she was being watched. Look, the messages were correct.
我们在他的狂欢派对中。我们会为保罗（巴勃罗）去死，也会为他入狱。麦德林贩毒集团是一个大家庭。当路易斯的报道搭档玛丽亚·伊诺霍萨（Maria Hinojosa）还是个年轻记者时，她来到麦德林为《滚石》杂志和其他新闻媒体报道这场冲突。她记得曾收到过贩毒集团的威胁。而爸爸告诉她，是的，她一直被监看。听着，这些信息是正确的。
The boss always notified the journalist so they would leave. You should thank God we didn't kill you. You were at great risk of us killing you because in a war, you have to shoot everyone. Let's be honest, we were at war, Maria. I'm worried that my father also fought as a captain for Columbia's National Police.
老大总是会通知记者，好让他们离开。你们应该感谢上帝，我们没有杀了你们。你们有极大的危险被我们杀死，因为在战争中，你必须向所有人开枪。老实说，我们当时在打仗，玛丽亚。我担心我的父亲也曾作为哥伦比亚国家警察的一名队长战斗过。
Because of his father's role, Luis and his brother had to learn things that most little kids don't have to learn about. Like when Luis was five or six years old, there was an explosion at a mall next door. It was strange because it was so close to her house, and I remember asking my mother if he was safe to return to the mall. Now long after that, my father left the Antenarcotx unit and joined the National Oil Company. He was the head of security and logistics for an oil pipeline being built through dangerous territory.
由于父亲的角色，路易斯和他的哥哥不得不学习大多数小孩子不需要学习的事情。比如路易斯五六岁的时候，隔壁的一个商场发生了爆炸。这很奇怪，因为它离她（他）家很近，我记得我问母亲回到商场是否安全。在那之后不久，我父亲离开缉毒局，加入了国家石油公司。他是为危险地区铺设的石油管道的安全与后勤主管。
It went through both narca control land and FARC territories. The FARC, short for the revolutionary armed forces of Colombia, were a leftist guerrilla group who took up arms against the government in 1964. By the late 80s, they were the largest rebel group in Latin America. And at the same time as the Medine cartel, they started drug trafficking and kidnapping to fund their war against the state. One weekend, while my mother and my brother and I were out of town visiting my grandmother, we turned on the TV and saw the breaking news that the FARC rebels had attacked a pipeline
它穿过了毒枭控制的土地和哥伦比亚革命武装力量（FARC）的领土。哥伦比亚革命武装力量（FARC，哥伦比亚革命武装力量的简称）是一个左翼游击队组织，于 1964 年拿起武器反对政府。到 80 年代末，他们是拉丁美洲最大的反叛组织。与此同时，麦德林贩毒集团也开始了毒品走私和绑架活动，以为他们对抗国家的战争筹集资金。有一个周末，我和母亲、哥哥不在城里去看望祖母，我们打开电视，看到了突发新闻：FARC 游击队员袭击了一条管道
where my father was working. The news anchor said, rebels had taken hostages, and one of those hostages was my father. In the past, when he was with the National Police, my father had fought the same farkin surgeons and they knew who he was, their enemy. Plus, my father was easy to recognize. Standing tall at about 6'3", slim with an arrogant arrogant arrogant arrogant arrogant arrogant arrogant arrogant arrogant arrogant arrogant arrogant arrogant arrogant arrogant arrogant arrogant So when my mother saw this on TV, she said she knew my father would die.
我父亲当时正在那里工作。新闻主播说，叛军劫持了人质，其中一个人质就是我父亲。过去，当他在国家警察部队时，我父亲曾与这些 farkin（应为 FARC 游击队员）外科医生（应为游击队员）战斗过，他们知道他是谁，是他们的敌人。此外，我父亲很容易被认出来。身高 6 英尺 3 英寸（约 1.9 米），身材修长，带着傲慢……（此处原文重复）。所以当母亲在电视上看到这一幕时，她说她知道父亲会死。
The FARC rebels eventually freed the other hostages, but they kept my father. They held a war tribunal, and then executed him. Right before his death, my father was able to leave a message that would later get passed on to my mother. He told her that she knew how to be strong. They had prepared for this moment. He was not her duty to race us and get us a heading life. And that he was sorry.
FARC 叛军最终释放了其他人质，但留下了我父亲。他们举行了军事法庭，然后处决了他。就在去世前不久，我父亲留下了一条后来传给我母亲的信息。他告诉她，她知道如何坚强。他们已经为这一刻做好了准备。抚养我们并过上美好的生活不是她的责任。而且他很抱歉。
He was sorry that their time had run out so suddenly. How old were you? I was almost six. I was almost six years old. The funeral was paid for by the military, the national police, the whole ceremony. It was surreal. And I remember at the funeral home and I kept on asking, when is it going to wake up? So when is this over?
他很抱歉，他们的时间这么快就用完了。你当时多大？我快六岁了。我快六岁了。葬礼由军方、国家警察出资，整个仪式。太超现实了。我记得在殡仪馆里，我一直在问，他什么时候醒来？那么这什么时候结束？
When is it going to wake up and play? Just like my family, there were many other families in Medellin that were mourning. The same year my father's death, in 1991, the city's murder rate peaked. The cartel created fear through the idea that violence can strike anyone at any time. Around this same time, Escobar made a deal with the Colombian state.
什么时候才能醒来玩耍？就像我的家人一样，麦德林还有许多其他家庭在哀悼。在我父亲去世的那一年，即 1991 年，该市的谋杀率达到了顶峰。贩毒集团通过“暴力可以随时随地袭击任何人”的想法制造了恐惧。大约在这个时候，埃斯科瓦尔与哥伦比亚国家达成了一项协议。
The extradition of Colombian citizens to the US had been prohibited by a newly approved Columbian Constitution, so that possibility was now off the table. Escobar agreed to surrender to authorities and to stop all criminal activity, in exchange for a reduced sentence and preferential treatment, including no extradition to the United States. And he got very preferential treatment. Escobar was locked up in his own luxurious private prison, but built specially for him.
新批准的哥伦比亚宪法禁止将哥伦比亚公民引渡到美国，因此这种可能性现在已经不复存在了。埃斯科瓦尔同意向当局自首并停止所有犯罪活动，以换取减刑和优惠待遇，包括不被引渡到美国。他得到了非常优惠的待遇。埃斯科瓦尔被关在自己的豪华私人监狱里，那是专门为他建造的。
He was called a la catedral, and he featured a soccer field, a bar, a giant dollhouse, a jacuzzi, and a waterfall. Then it became clear that Escobar was continuing to orchestrate criminal activities from within the prison. Authorities made plans to move them to a new location, but Escobar escaped before they could. There was a man hunt, and in December 1993, Escobar died in a shootout. But even before Escobar died, the city had undertaken an ambitious new project to try to figure out how to pull Medine out of the drug-fueled violence that had affected the city for so long. This is Sandra Arenas again.
它被称为“大教堂”（La Catedral），里面有一个足球场、一个酒吧、一个巨大的玩具屋、一个按摩浴缸和一个瀑布。随后，人们发现埃斯科瓦尔继续在狱中策划犯罪活动。当局计划将他们转移到一个新地点，但埃斯科瓦尔在他们转移之前就逃跑了。经过搜捕，1993 年 12 月，埃斯科瓦尔在一次枪战中身亡。但甚至在埃斯科瓦尔死之前，该市就着手实施了一项雄心勃勃的新项目，试图找出如何让麦德林摆脱长期影响该市的毒品暴力。这是桑德拉·阿雷纳斯。
She says that he was doing the worst of the violence, that Medellín began to figure out the formula for its own transformation. What happened was the national government sent policy makers out into the neighborhoods of Medín, especially the Camunas, to hold public forums and to meet with people from all across the city. And who were the leaders, the leaders, the leaders, the leaders, the educators, the church? Arenas says these meetings were attended by community leaders, teachers, religious figures, and public servants.
她说，正是在暴力最严重的时候，麦德林才开始摸索出自身转型的秘诀。发生的事情是，国家政府将政策制定者派往麦德林的社区，特别是卡姆纳斯，举行公开论坛，并与来自全市各族人民见面。领导者、领导者、领导者、教育工作者、教会都是谁？阿雷纳斯说，社区领袖、教师、宗教人士和公务员都参加了这些会议。
Academics, artists, and everyday citizens came to. Arena says that in the forums, they figured out that the city needed to reclaim public spaces, places where people could meet up and talk. Many of these spaces, like parks and plazas, had been abandoned because people were afraid to be outside with all the violence. People also said the city needed to invest in community groups. There were already lots of artists' collectives and community organizations doing important work in the Camunas.
学者、艺术家和普通市民也来了。阿雷纳斯说，他们在论坛上发现，这座城市需要收复公共空间，即人们可以见面和交谈的地方。其中许多空间，如公园和广场，都被废弃了，因为人们害怕外面有暴力。人们还表示，这座城市需要投资于社区团体。已经有许多艺术家集体和社区组织在卡姆纳斯做着重要的工作。
They just needed more support. And finally, the city could no longer neglect and ignore the Camunas on the steep hills above the city center. Those neighborhoods needed to be integrated with the rest of Medellin. The city needed a modern metro system. Transporte público, Medellin, and all the systems that I've understood more as a process of inclusion. That's Natalia Castanio, and she says that the public transportation system became a way to create a sense of inclusion throughout the city. Castanio is an architect, and she
他们只是需要更多的支持。最后，这座城市不能再忽视和无视市中心上方陡峭山丘上的卡姆纳斯。这些 neighborhoods（社区）需要与麦德林的其余部分融为一体。这座城市需要一个现代化的地铁系统。公共交通，麦德林，以及我更理解为包容过程的所有系统。这是娜塔莉亚·卡斯塔尼奥（Natalia Castano），她说公共交通系统成为了在整个城市营造包容感的一种方式。卡斯塔尼奥是一名建筑师，她
helped to implement some of the ideas that came out of those throughout the city. Castanos and architects, and she helped to implement some of the ideas that came out of those early community meetings. In 1995, the many metro opened, linking parts of the previously fragmented city. The richest southern district was now easily connected with the poor Camunas to the north. In the 90s, I was seeing a very critical moment
帮助落实了早期社区会议产生的一些想法。1995 年，麦德林地铁开通，连接了以前碎片化的城市的各个部分。最富有的南部地区现在与北部贫穷的卡姆纳斯轻松连接起来。在 90 年代，我看到了一个非常关键的时刻
for all the acting violent that was being given. Natalia says, I was living in a very critical moment for all the violent acts that were being given. Natalia says they were living in a time when violent attacks, car bombs and assassinations were common. And obviously, the metro's infrastructure could be targeted. The drug cartel hitmen were part of a conservative managing culture and many of them were Catholic. So the city came up with the idea of placing a statue of the Virgin Mary in each one of the metro stations. They thought it would be a reminder to keep things calm and peaceful in the trains.
对于所有正在发生的暴力行为。娜塔莉亚说，我生活在一个暴行、汽车炸弹和暗杀常见的关键时期。显然，地铁基础设施可能会成为攻击目标。贩毒集团的杀手是保守的麦德林文化的一部分，他们中有许多人是天主教徒。因此，该市想出了在每个地铁站放置一尊圣母玛利亚雕像的主意。他们认为这会提醒人们在火车上保持冷静和平和。
To complement the metro, the city built something else, an innovative system of cable cars that went right up the steep mountain sides to length the camunas to the rest of the city. And this made a huge difference. It had once taken people in the camunas over an hour to get to the city. And this made a huge difference. It had once taken people in the Camuna's over an hour to get to the city center. Now it took more like 15 or 20 minutes. Before, people in the Camuna used to say, I need to go to Medellin to run an errand.
为了补充地铁，该市还建造了另一项设施：一个创新的缆车系统，直达陡峭的山坡，将卡姆纳斯与城市的其他地方连接起来。这产生了巨大的影响。过去，卡姆纳斯的人们需要一个多小时才能到达城市。这产生了巨大的影响。过去，卡姆纳斯的人们需要一个多小时才能到达市中心。现在只需要 15 到 20 分钟左右。以前，卡姆纳斯的人们常说：“我需要去麦德林办点事。”
Now, they felt like they were part of Medellin, like they belonged. There was other investment in the Camuna's too. The city built big public libraries, parks, soccer fields, job training centers, and health clinics, and they poured money into already existing artists' collectives and community organizations. Natalia says it's because the city had come to realize that they owed the Camus. Those neighborhoods had been neglected and underserved in the past. In a way Medin's big innovation was to tackle crime and violence not through more policing, but through urban planning, infrastructure, and social programs. They invested in neighborhoods
现在，他们觉得自己是麦德林的一部分，觉得自己属于这里。卡姆纳斯也有其他投资。该市建造了大型公共图书馆、公园、足球场、职业培训中心和健康诊所，并将资金注入现有的艺术家集体和社区组织。娜塔莉亚说，这是因为这座城市已经意识到他们亏欠卡姆纳斯。过去这些社区被忽视和剥夺了应有的服务。在某种程度上，麦德林的大创新不是通过更多的警力来打击犯罪和暴力，而是通过城市规划、基础设施和社会政策。他们投资于社区
that had been the most isolated and where the cartels had previously had the most success recruiting members. And the city started to change. Commute times dropped, soccer fields stayed lit up into the night. The city also built inviting new outdoor spaces, and the streets became busy again. And along with all these changes, the murder rate plummeted by 90% from its peak in 1991 to today. The approach to urban planning that developed in Medine has now become known as social urbanism. It was a grassroots approach, not a top-down one, and people all over the world now look to Medine as an example for how to do this well.
这些社区曾是最孤立的，也是贩毒集团以前招募成员最成功的地方。这座城市开始发生变化。通勤时间缩短了，足球场彻夜灯火通明。这座城市还建造了迷人的全新户外空间，街道再次变得热闹起来。伴随着所有这些变化，谋杀率从 1991 年的最高峰暴跌了 90%，一直延续到今天。麦德林发展起来的城市规划方法现在被称为“社会城市主义”（Social Urbanism）。这是一种自下而上的方法，而不是自上而下的方法，世界各地的人们现在都将麦德林视为如何做好这一工作的榜样。
Of course, there were other reasons the violence declined in Medine. The Medine cartel was dismantled. The economy was getting stronger, and a series of progressive mayors kept building on each other's work. But the urban planning and public transportation did play a big role. Mariennai wanted to see this change for ourselves, so we met our way to Camuna 13, historically one of the most violent and stigmatized neighborhoods in the city. Camuna 13 is a dense neighborhood built on a steep hillside and now running right up to the middle of it. Are these massive outdoor escalators?
当然，麦德林暴力事件减少还有其他原因。麦德林贩毒集团被瓦解了。经济正在走强，一任又一任进步的市长在前人的基础上不断建设。但城市规划和公共交通确实发挥了重要作用。玛丽安娜（Maria）想亲眼看看这种变化，于是我们前往 13 区（Comuna 13），历史上该市最暴力、污名化最严重的社区之一。13 区是一个建在陡峭山坡上的密集社区，现在一直延伸到它的中间。这些巨大的户外自动扶梯是什么？
What is an escalator doing in the middle of an outdoor community? And there's another escalator, whoa, just the notion that you're writing escalators up a hill, literally, and it's taking you to the top of the city on escalators that are outdoors. But what you're also seeing is everywhere you turn, there's art, there's huge mural arts at every turn. I found the top of the escalator. We see huge paintings and kids breakdancing in beatboxing. 30 years ago, this neighborhood was a dangerous place. Police would have been afraid to come here, and now it's flourishing with art and color
为什么户外社区中间会有扶梯？还有另一个扶梯，哇，仅仅是你在山上坐扶梯的概念，字面意思，它通过户外的扶梯把你带到城市的顶部。但你同时看到的是，无论你转向哪里，都有艺术，每个转角都有巨大的壁画艺术。我找到了扶梯的顶部。我们看到巨大的画作和孩子们在跳霹雳舞（breakdance）和 beatbox。30 年代（应为 30 年前），这个社区是个危险的地方。警察会害怕来这里，而现在它正蓬勃发展着艺术、色彩
and tourists from all over the world. Foreign tourism has gone up by 250% in Colombia in the last decade, and many of those tourists are coming actually because of the city's drug trafficking legacy. It's something the locals call Narco Tourism. Even Popeye is cashing in on the interest in this type of tourism, which has only been amplified by the hit Netflix show Narcos. He leads drug-related tours of Medellin, taking people to sites around the city like Pablo Escobar's grave. And it's good that Medine is safe enough for tourists now.
以及来自世界各地的游客。在过去的十年里，哥伦比亚的外国旅游业增长了 250%，其中许多游客实际上是因为该市的毒品走私遗产而来的。当地人称之为“毒品旅游”（Narco Tourism）。甚至“大力水手”也在利用人们对这种旅游的兴趣赚钱，而 Netflix 热播剧《毒贩》（Narcos）更是放大了这种兴趣。他带领游客进行与毒品相关的麦德林之旅，带人们参观巴勃罗·埃斯科瓦尔墓等城市周围的地点。麦德林现在对游客来说足够安全，这是一件好事。
But there's also something uncomfortable about knowing that Popeye is now profiting off a glorified version of the city's violent past. The city has a complicated relationship with this kind of narco tourism. One of the main narco tourism sites is a place called Edificio Monaco. It's the building compound where Pablo Escobar is to live with his family and tourists love to visit it. But Manine's current mayor, Federico Gatieres, says that they're actually planning to tear down Edificio Monaco. He says that in displays, they're going to build a park in remembrance of the victims,
但一想到“大力水手”现在正从该市暴力过去的被美化版本中牟取暴利，也让人感到有些不舒服。这座城市对这种毒品旅游有着复杂的情感。主要的毒品旅游景点之一是一个叫“摩纳哥大楼”（Edificio Monaco）的地方。这是巴勃罗·埃斯科瓦尔曾经与家人居住的建筑大院，游客们喜欢参观它。但麦德林现任市长费德里科·古铁雷斯（Federico Gutierrez）表示，他们实际上正计划拆除摩纳哥大楼。他说，在展示中，他们将建造一个公园来缅怀受害者，
not to hide that history, but to transform it, because part of healing is not forgetting. He says that the terrible things that took place in the city can't be forgotten, because that's what made the city hit rock bottom. And hitting rock bottom is what eventually made people come together again as a society. It is undeniable that Medine today is a different city. There's still massive inequality and drug trafficking. There are still criminal gangs that control parts of the city and sometimes extort people and businesses.
不是为了掩盖这段历史，而是为了改变它，因为疗愈的一部分就是不忘记。他说，这座城市发生的恐怖事件不能被忘记，因为这正是让这座城市跌入谷底的原因。而跌入谷底最终让人们作为社会再次走到了一起。不可否认，今天的麦德林是一座不同的城市。这里仍然存在巨大的不平等和毒品走私。仍然有犯罪帮派控制着城市的部分地区，有时勒索人和企业。
But it's way more democratic, inclusive, and peaceful than it was 30 years ago. And today you can take a trip across town that would have been impossible a few decades ago. In the morning you can get on the Metro downtown, in a station decorated with Virgin Mary statues. You can ride up into the Camunas on an outdoor escalator that carries you past murals and beat boxers. And then, as evening descends, not worrying about any curfew, you can hop on a cable car and float back down the mountainside. The slopes of the Camuna's softening behind you in the twilight. The lights of the city center becoming clearer as you draw closer and closer.
但它比 30 年前更加民主、包容和和平。今天，你可以进行一次几十年前不可能实现的跨城旅行。早上，你可以登上市中心的地铁，在装饰有圣母玛利亚雕像的车站。你可以坐着户外扶梯进入卡姆纳斯，扶梯带你穿过壁画和 beatbox 表演者。然后，随着夜幕降临，无需担心任何宵禁，你可以跳上缆车，在山腰上缓缓漂回。卡姆纳斯的山坡在黄昏中渐渐变得柔和。随着你越来越近，市中心的灯光变得越来越清晰。
It streets and shops and buses bustling with life, with people from all over Medin, from all over the world. A city finally connected. We'll talk more with reporter Luis Gayo about the complexities of narco-tourism and his decision to return to Colombia after years of living in the United States. Plus, an extended preview of a brand new radio-topia show called Zigzac. Right after this. We're back with Louise Gio who reported our story this week. In the late 90s, about five years after his father's death, Louise and his family left Columbia and moved to Seattle. But Louise decided to move back to Columbia a few years ago, and we wanted to hear more
它的街道、商店和公共汽车充满了生机，充满了来自麦德林各地、世界各地的人们。一座终于重新连接的城市。我们稍后将与记者路易斯·吉奥（Luis Gayo）讨论毒品旅游的复杂性，以及他在美国生活多年后决定返回哥伦比亚的决定。此外，还有一档名为 Zigzac 的全新电台节目的大型预告片。马上回来。我们回来了，本周我们的故事由路易斯·吉奥报道。90 年代末，在他父亲去世大约五年后，路易斯和他的家人离开哥伦比亚搬到了西雅图。但路易斯几年前决定搬回哥伦比亚，我们想听听更多
from him about what it's been like to return. We were especially curious about his reactions to the Narco-Tourism as someone who has a very personal connection to that history. So we called him up, he was traveling in Spain when we talked to him. I mean, I want people to come to Columbia, I want people to visit the country so they could understand the plays, they can get a sense of what it's really like as opposed to what they see on television. So I think it's a positive thing, more people are coming to Colombia.
关于他回去后的感受。作为一个与这段历史有着非常私密联系的人，我们对他对毒品旅游的反应尤其好奇。所以我们打电话给他，我们通话时他正在西班牙旅行。我的意思是，我希望人们来哥伦比亚，我希望人们访问这个国家，这样他们才能了解这些地方，他们可以了解真实的情况，而不是他们在电视上看到的那样。所以我认为这是一件积极的事情，更多的人来到哥伦比亚。
However, the people coming only to see that part of Colombia kind of perpetuates the stigma and perpetuates. Kind of that stereotype that many of us are trying to move on from. And it's problematic because like many people who are coming into Colombia, into managing and visiting those spaces, they find this narrative of Pablo Escobar, of the violence, of you know, the drug of the drug bosses, a little bit seductive and entertaining, while at the same time, that same narrative, the same history was our reality at the time.
然而，那些只为了看哥伦比亚那一部分而来的游客，在某种程度上延续了污名化，并延续了。这种刻板印象正是我们许多人正试图摆脱的。这很有问题，因为就像许多来到哥伦比亚、来到麦德林并参观这些地方的人一样，他们发现巴勃罗·埃斯科瓦尔、暴力、毒品大佬的叙事有点诱人且具有娱乐性，而与此同时，同样的叙事、这段历史在当时就是我们的现实。
It was our reality, it was our daily lives, and all that suffering was real, so he wasn't just like TV show, suffering was real. So like, it wasn't just like, you know, a TV show, it was real terror. And is it hard for you to see the ways that people like Pablo Escobar and Popeye have been turned into these sort of glamorized figures? So it says, I see why this narrative is seductive and this narrative is entertaining for many people
这是我们的现实，这是我们的日常生活，所有的痛苦都是真实的，所以它不只是像电视节目，痛苦是真实的。所以，它不只是像，你知道的，一个电视节目，那是真正的恐怖。看到像巴勃罗·埃斯科瓦尔和“大力水手”这样的人被塑造成这种被美化的形象，对你来说很难接受吗？所以他说，我明白为什么这种叙事对许多人来说很有诱惑力，也很有娱乐性
because it's kind of like this man created an empire out of nothing more or less, but at the same time, yeah, like we can't forget that they are responsible, public abide and papa, they're responsible for the suffering of and the deaths and the killing and the terror. Yeah, I can't overlook that. You might be entertaining for a TV show or a movie, but in real life, these guys are psychopaths. So given all the suffering that you've seen and experienced with the conflict between the cartels and the government and the FARC, there's the leftist guerrillas who murdered your father. Why did you decide to move back to Columbia after so many years away? I decided to go back to Columbia because it was around the same time that the FARC and the government were finishing up signing their peace agreements.
因为这有点像这个人凭空建立了一个帝国，或多或少是这样的，但与此同时，是的，就像我们不能忘记他们负有责任一样，巴勃罗和“大力水手”，他们对苦难、死亡、杀戮和恐怖负有责任。是的，我不能忽视这一点。电视节目或电影可能很有娱乐性，但在现实中，这些人都是精神病患者。鉴于你所看到和经历的所有苦难，贩毒集团与政府的冲突以及 FARC（谋杀你父亲的左翼游击队），你在离开这么多年后，为什么决定搬回哥伦比亚？我决定回到哥伦比亚，因为那正值 FARC 和政府最后敲定和平协议的时候。
So there was a peace accord that they were finalizing. And I went both as a journalist, but I also went as a Colombian victim of the violence, victim of the conflict. And yeah, I just wanted to maybe come back and heal both collectively and, you know, and personally. And I wanted to be part of that crucial time in our history where, you know, 50 years of, you know, over 50 years of conflict were, you know, we're coming to an end. You know, the longest running conflict in the world was coming to an end. There was a concert that you went to that was a celebration of the signing of the Peace Accord
所以他们当时正在敲定一项和平协议。我回去既是以记者的身份，但我也以哥伦比亚暴力受害者、冲突受害者的身份回去。是的，我只是想也许可以回去，在集体和个人层面进行疗愈。我希望成为我们历史中那个关键时刻的一部分，你知道，长达 50 年的冲突，你知道，超过 50 年的冲突正在走向终结。世界上持续时间最长的冲突即将结束。你参加了一个庆祝签署和平协议的音乐听（应为音乐会）
and it sounds like it was a really significant moment for you. Can you tell us that story? So I say that this moment, you know, crystallized for me last year when I went to a concert celebrating the signing of the Peace of court in Boatta. And so they had a concert in the main square of Boatta. And at the concert, most of everyone was wearing white and wavy and white flags,
听起来这对你来说是一个非常重要的时刻。你能给我们讲讲那个故事吗？所以我觉得这个时刻，你知道的，去年我去波哥大参加庆祝签署和平协议的音乐会时，对我来说变得具象化了。他们在波哥大主广场举办了一场音乐会。在音乐会上，几乎每个人都穿着白色的衣服，挥舞着白色的旗帜，
and they had white balloons celebrating the piece of court. However, I saw other people wearing red shirts and waving red flags, and the friend I was with who works with the president. She told me she confirmed that the people wearing the red shirts were in fact, FARC, Urban Militia members. So there were members of the FARC, but they were like the Bull of Tach after. And then in the middle of the folk, but in the Bogota chapter. And then in the middle of the concert, the lead singer from this Colombian rock band, Artesia Pelaos, told everyone to hug a stranger in the name of peace. Like to hug somebody you did not come with. And then right next to me was this young man, college aged, and he was wearing a red shirt, and he approached me, and he was drinking So, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, when I realized, wow, this person is or was part of the FARC,
他们拿着白色的气球庆祝和平协议。然而，我看到其他人穿着红色的衬衫，挥舞着红色的旗帜，和我一起的一位总统府工作人员朋友告诉我，她证实穿红色衬衫的人实际上是 FARC 城市民兵成员。所以有 FARC 的成员，但他们就像是波哥大分支。然后，在音乐会进行到一半时，哥伦比亚摇滚乐队 Artesia Pelaos 的主唱告诉每个人为了和平去拥抱一个陌生人。就像去拥抱一个不是跟你一起来的人。然后我旁边正好有这个年轻人，大学年纪，他穿着一件红衬衫，他向我走来，他在喝酒……（录音中断/省略）。当我意识到，哇，这个人是或曾经是 FARC 的一部分，
the same group that killed my father. But the moment was very emotional. There were people in tears, there were people very moved from what was happening. And I realized at that moment, this is the new, peaceful Columbia. That was reporter Luis Gio, recording himself on his iPhone in Spain. This story was produced by Luis Gio,
杀害我父亲的同一个组织。但那一刻非常激动人心。有人流泪，有人为发生的事情深受感动。我当时意识到，这就是全新、和平的哥伦比亚。那是记者路易斯·吉奥（Luis Gio）在西班牙用iPhone录下的自己。这个故事由路易斯·吉奥制作，
edited by Fernanda Hachavary and Marlon Bishop, research assistants on this episode by Tom Colligan, production help from Sarah Coveto. Our program today was a collaboration with Latino USA. If you don't know them, they're a great podcast and radio show with an inside look at Latino life, culture, history, and politics. It's in English and it's not just for Latinos. There is something for everyone. Check it out. We have a brand new show in radio atopia. It's called the Zigzag. Check it out. When they were raising money for their company, they looked into investments and grants and found those traditional paths unreliable and required them to give up too much control. So they're trying out something completely new. Here's an extended preview of Zigzag.
由费尔南达·哈查瓦里（Fernanda Hachavary）和马龙·毕晓普（Marlon Bishop）剪辑，本集的研究助理是汤姆·科利根（Tom Colligan），制作协助来自萨拉·科韦托（Sarah Coveto）。我们今天的节目是与“拉丁美洲美国”（Latino USA）合作推出的。如果你不了解他们，他们是一个伟大的播客和广播节目，深入探讨拉丁裔的生活、文化、历史和政治。它是英语的，不仅仅面向拉丁裔。每个人都能从中找到适合自己的内容。去看看吧。我们在广播乌托邦（RadioTopia）有一个全新的节目。它叫《之字形》（Zigzag）。去看看吧。当他们为自己的公司筹集资金时，他们研究了投资和赠款，发现那些传统途径不可靠，而且需要他们放弃太多的控制权。因此，他们正在尝试一种全新方法。以下是《之字形》的加长预告片。
So early on, when we've been talking to everyone we knew to figure out like really should we start our own company, I had met with a friend of a friend who actually advised media startups. His name is Josh Benson. And then Josh called me back. Because the more he thought about it, since we'd had our first conversation, the more he thought that actually, Jen and I would be a great fit
所以早在刚开始时，当我们和所有认识的人交谈，想弄清楚我们是否真的应该创业时，我曾见过一个朋友的朋友，他实际上是为媒体初创公司提供咨询的。他的名字叫乔什·本森（Josh Benson）。后来乔什给我回了电话。因为他越想越觉得，自从我们第一次交谈以来，他越觉得其实詹和我非常适合
for this other startup he was working with. It was kind of hard to explain, but the gist of it was that this group of techies and journalists were building something that would throw good journalism a lifeline, help it survive in a world now driven by free Facebook news feeds. They were called civil, and thanks to the generosity of a multi-billionaire, they had money. They actually had grants to give out to journalists with proven track records, like us. No strings attached. The journalists would own their work. All they had to do was contribute
他正在合作的另一个初创公司。这有点难以解释，但大意是这群科技人员和记者正在构建一个东西，它将为优秀的新闻业提供一根救命稻草，帮助它在一个现在由免费脸书（Facebook）新闻动态主导的世界中生存下来。他们被称为“公民”（Civil），多亏了一位亿万富翁的慷慨解囊，他们有资金。他们实际上有赠款可以发给拥有良好过往记录的记者，比如我们。没有任何附加条件。记者将拥有自己的作品。他们唯一要做的就是贡献
to the civil platform. And the way they were making this media fantasy come true? It was something called the blockchain. Jen and I had heard of the blockchain, you may have too. We were entirely sure how it worked or what it had to do with journalism. And like most people, we pretty much equated it with Bitcoin, the most popular cryptocurrency that had made the people who bought in early, really, really rich. And according to memes, it seemed to compel them to by-lamp reginis. Why the hell would we want anything to do with that? But after doing some research, we started to understand.
给“公民”平台。他们是如何让这个媒体幻想成真的？那是一个叫做区块链的东西。我和詹听说过区块链，你可能也听说过。我们完全不确定它是如何运作的，或者它与新闻业有什么关系。就像大多数人一样，我们基本上把它等同于比特币，那个让早期买入的人变得非常非常富有的最流行的加密货币。根据表情包，它似乎还迫使他们去买兰博基尼。我们为什么会想跟那种东西扯上关系？但在做了一些研究之后，我们开始明白了。
Blockchain was just the technology that made Bitcoin possible. But it could, maybe, do so much more than just make some dudes rich enough to buy lambos. The we read the more we felt like actually the blockchain could be a second chance for the internet Because over the last few years we'd seen that the promise of the web Information and access for everyone and had been totally perverted But the blockchain if it really got off the, could do things like protect people's identity, help get aid faster to natural disasters, sustain the poorest populations, maybe even help protect democracy, and save important struggling industries like journalism.
区块链只是让比特币成为可能的底层技术。但是，它可能，也许能做更多的事情，而不仅仅是让一些家伙富得可以买兰博基尼。我们读得越多，就越觉得区块链实际上可能是互联网的第二次机会，因为在过去几年里，我们看到网络的承诺——为每个人提供信息和获取途径——已经被完全扭曲了。但是，区块链如果真正推广开来，可以做一些事情，比如保护人们的身份，帮助更快地向自然灾害提供援助，维持最贫困人口的生活，甚至可能帮助保护民主，并拯救像新闻业这样举步维艰的重要行业。
These are big promises. Yeah. But man, after hearing what civil was doing with the blockchain, we were kind of stoked. Josh? Hi. How are you? We went to see Josh Benson, our blockchain matchmaker at his WeWork office on 23rd Street.
这些都是宏伟的承诺。是的。但是天哪，在听到“公民”利用区块链在做什么之后，我们有点兴奋。乔什？嗨。你好吗？我们去23街的WeWork办公室见我们的区块链媒人乔什·本森了。
Stop the way I said this. So here, guys, please make yourself a little bit more. Okay, you sure? Okay, thank you. Very sure. Because I just think you guys are going to be obviously like a super interesting interactive proposition to bunch of places. It's like we know some people who are doing interesting things with podcasts and it's just like worth thinking about all that stuff because why the hell not?
停下我说话的方式。那么在这里，伙计们，请随便一点。好的，你确定吗？好的，谢谢。非常确定。因为我只是认为你们显然会成为一个对许多地方都超级有趣且互动的命题。就像我们认识一些正在用播客做有趣事情的人，这就像值得考虑所有这些事情，因为为什么不呢？
Yes, that's right. We have this weird crazy blue sky opportunity at the moment and so we just should be thinking about all that stuff. And to get Tom and Catherine towards it. Once we left the meeting, there was no need to play it cool anymore. Jen and I wanted in. Just give me three words.
是的，没错。我们目前有一个奇怪而疯狂的广阔机遇，所以我们应该考虑所有这些事情。并引导汤姆和凯瑟琳朝着这个方向发展。一旦我们离开会议，就没有必要再假装冷酷了。我和詹都想加入。只给我三个词。
Ah! Ah! What, I mean, are you, are you psyched? I'm so psyched. Right? Isn't this like, it's kind of, I mean, I'm scared to say like, it sounds too good to me true, but like, it's perfect for but like it's perfect for us.
啊！啊！什么，我的意思是，你们，你们兴奋吗？我太兴奋了。对吧？这难道不是像，这有点，我的意思是，我不敢说，听起来好得令人难以置信，但像，它对我们来说是完美的，但像它对我们来说是完美的。
It's perfect for us. It's gonna help with us launching. It's gonna help with everything. It's also gonna be super fun. And it's a beautiful concept that's meant to help and support journalists doing good work. Yay! And civil wanted us to. Especially when we told them what we do with the grant they gave us.
这太适合我们了。它将帮助我们启动。它将帮助一切。这也将超级有趣。这是一个美好的概念，旨在帮助和支持做好工作的记者。耶！“公民”希望我们这么做。尤其是当我们告诉他们我们用他们给的赠款做了什么时。
Make our first podcast. One that actually explained in normal, non-hard-core techy language, what the hell the blockchain is. Because here's the thing, listeners, that grants its civil gave us. It was half real money. And the other half is a new cryptocurrency that they call civil tokens.
制作我们的第一个播客。一个真正用普通、非死硬科技语言解释区块链到底是什么的播客。因为事情是这样的，听众朋友们，“公民”给我们的赠款。一半是真金白银。另一半是一种他们称之为“公民代币”的新加密货币。
These tokens have no value yet, but after they get auctioned off to the public, they could be worth quite a lot, or nothing at all. Join Manouche and Jen in zigzag as they explore big issues of women, tech, journalism and capitalism. It's gonna be a fun journey and you're finally going to understand the blockchain.
这些代币目前没有任何价值，但在它们向公众拍卖之后，它们可能会变得非常值钱，或者一文不值。加入玛努什（Manouche）和詹（Jen）的《之字形》，探索女性、科技、新闻和资本主义的重大问题。这将会是一段有趣的旅程，你终于会理解区块链了。
Episodes 1 and 2 are out right now. Episodes 3 drops this week if you want to be my friend. Download it and listen to it and follow along with me and let me know what you think about it on Twitter. I have no idea if this is going to work or how it's going to end. And that's why it's fun. Zigzag from RadioTopia. Find it at zigzagpod.com on Radiotopia.fm and
第1集和第2集现在已经发布。如果你想成为我的朋友，第3集本周上线。下载它，收听它，跟我一起关注它，并在推特（Twitter）上让我知道你对它的看法。我不知道这是否会成功，也不知道它将如何结束。这就是它的乐趣所在。来自RadioTopia的《之字形》。在zigzagpod.com、Radiotopia.fm上找到它，以及
wallsevelink in our show notes. Alongside the amazing team at Latino USA, our show was produced and edited this week by Senior Editor Delaney Hall. Mixed in tech production by Sharif Usif, Music by Sean Rial. The rest of the team is Senior Producer Katie Mingle, Digital Director Kurt Colstead, Joe Rosenberg, Avery Trollerman, Vivian Lee, Taren Mazza, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced, on Radio Row, in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. 99% of visible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting.
在我们节目文稿中的wallsevelink。除了“拉丁美洲美国”的精彩团队外，我们本周的节目由资深编辑德兰妮·霍尔（Delaney Hall）制作和剪辑。混音与技术制作由谢里夫·乌西夫（Sharif Usif）负责，音乐由肖恩·里亚尔（Sean Rial）创作。其余团队成员包括高级制作人凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）、数字总监库尔特·科尔斯特ッド（Kurt Colstead）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、艾弗里·特罗勒曼（Avery Trollerman）、薇薇安·李（Vivian Lee）、特伦·马扎（Taren Mazza）以及我罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的市中心“无线电街”（Radio Row）制作。99%可见（99% Invisible）是来自PRX的Radio Topia成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的坚定的独立集体。
Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI Orc. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But on our website, we have pictures of cable cars and outdoor escalators and colorful camunas plus links to Latino USA and ZigZac. It's all there at 99pi.org. Radio tapio.
在radiotopia.fm上找到他们所有人。你可以在脸书（Facebook）上找到该节目并参与有关该节目的讨论。你可以在推特上@我 Roman Mars，并在 @99PI Orc 上@该节目。我们也在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上。但在我们的网站上，我们有缆车、户外自动扶梯和彩色卡穆纳的照片，以及通往“拉丁美洲美国”和《之字形》的链接。这一切都在 99pi.org 上。Radio tapio。
From PRX. from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自 PRX。来自 PRX。本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子以留下评论。